So your body is made up of trillions of cells,
and each cell has its own copy of the human genome.
>> So wait, you're saying that my body
has trillions of my genome, not just one?
>> Exactly. Your body is made up of trillions of cells, and because
each one has its own copy, you've got trillions of copies. It's what
makes cells different. They each read a slightly different A portion of the
instructions. For example a skin cell is a skin cell, and not a stomach
cell, because it's reading the skin chapter parts. And the stomach
cell is a stomach cell, not a blood cell, because it's reading
the stomach cell parts. And the blood cell is a blood
cell because it reads the blood cell parts. You get the idea.
>> So all my different traits, that make me me, you're saying it's
because my cells are reading different parts of this to make Me, me?
>> Exactly. These traits at an organismal level, at a
whole body level, are because different cells make up tissues,
the tissues are organized into organs, organs are organized into
your whole body. And then, we see a myriad of traits.
>> It's crazy how the body works.
>> It is pretty amazing. So think it's about time we wrapped up this
lesson pretty soon? So I want you to try answering one really tough question. I
want you to tell me in your own words, what is the human genome?
I want you to be clear, succinct,
but comprehensive, pulling on the information you've seen
so far in the exercises in these lessons. Use words
like chromosome, base pair, mitochondria, anything that you think you
need to answer that question. And save your answer because
we're going to come back to it in a future video.